if you have any questions about the show
if you have any comments about the show
we have a voicemail number which is two
one nine to david p you can call that
number anytime you want if it's 3am and
you're a presidential candidate you
probably shouldn't be tweeting about sex
tapes but if it's 3am and your viewer of
the david pakman show you absolutely
should be calling 2192 david p here's a
voicemail i received yesterday take a
listen so what's up what do the show
from your spare bedroom for but the
hatred mail on this one's gonna be good
keep up the good work he ok show did
yeah this is a reference to yesterday i
was doing the show on the road from
northampton massachusetts it was not my
spare bedroom that was actually my mom's
study david pakman show coming to you
from my mom's study in northampton
massachusetts yesterday uh but the audio
was good i have to tell you pat i
listened afterwards to my audio and that
mobile kit it's really working pretty
well other than the clicking noise which
you and i have spoken about people
actually said when they listen to it
they thought i was here when they
watched then they saw that I was
somewhere else but I'm pretty happy with
the the audio quality yeah we're gonna
be using that again in the future too so
it's make we have to make sure that we
get that right yes I can vouch for him
he wasn't in his spare bedroom right
that's cuz Pat was in my spare bedroom
just to verify that I wasn't there he
that that's where Pat was during
yesterday's show on today's bonus show
Leonardo DiCaprio the actor says climate
change deniers should not hold public
office we're going to talk about that
the Florida Democratic Party has
submitted nearly half a million voter
registration forms where is the
Republican Party of Florida has only
submitted 59,000 what does this tell us
about the early voting that is already
happening in Florida and WikiLeaks says
they will be releasing documents
relating to the US election in Google
over the next ten weeks what will that
contain we will discuss that and more on
today's bonus show the only way to sign
up for membership and get instant access
to the bonus show is by going to david
pakman
dotcom slash membership this is viewer
supported media and I encourage you to
sign up and I thank everybody sincerely
who has signed up in the last couple of
weeks